D Ford of the San Francisco 49ers here
on the Rich Eisen show how are you D
Ford I'm doing good must have been great
for you feeling get Mac out there run
around huh oh man it was excellent
I've been sick these last six weeks just
watching these big games and not being
able to help my team but I was so so
happy to be out so what's that like
sitting around and and watching your
teammates go on without you or doing
their best to to win hoping that you
come back what does that stop you know
anytime you have as a player anytime you
have an injury you are you feel removed
you're not removed but you feel removed
because there are practicing you're
rehabbing from 6:00 a.m. to 7:00 at
night you know doing everything you can
get back and you just don't feel part of
the team I know that's not what reality
but uh it's just tough to watch man
especially when these times well I know
I can have an impact on the game it's
tough but we did what we had to do and
now we're here what uh what is it like
being coached by Robert Sala we see what
he looks like in terms of his his I
guess zest for life and his his emotions
on his sleeve as he's coaching but what
is it like in meeting rooms with him
well chance to be a part of Gus Bradley
for a week at the Senior Bowl okay so
he's a protege he came from under their
system so he reminded me a lot of Gus
Bradley and that was that was one of the
more inspirational weeks of my life at
the Senior Bowl that week and when I got
here when I got traded here our first
team meeting I'll never forget he
reminds me he gave me that same energy
that same vibe he made me inspired to
play the game again and I don't think I
don't think people understand how hard
that is to continue every day to live up
to that expectation to keep your players
motivated and inspired he keeps us too
or he keeps he keeps us on our toes it's
just an amazing coach to be a part of
when you said playing football again
like that what do you mean by that
when you when you showed up to San
Francisco I mean you got paid are you
referring to the way that things ended
for you in Kansas City is that what
you're referring to
no I know you played the game for so
long it can become a little monotonous
you know but you can get in a little rut
in your blue team just he just finds
different ways to trigger that
inspiration that kid like inspiration
and never to the way things ended
I know it's import for the world it
might've ended that Lou in a AFC
Championship I don't think anybody even
expected that coming into that year but
uh but it's important to it's important
for players to trigger that kid like
inspiration because that's when great
clay happens and I'm just being here you
can play at your best when you're not
thinking and you're inspired to play d4
to the San Francisco 49ers here on the
Rich Eisen show that said you have this
it factor about UD that your teammates
are I've noticed I wanted to get your
reaction from this and Nick boasts a
quote after the game on Saturday Nick
said about you quote I told D I wish I
could scare people with my presence like
you do when a guard sees D Ford on them
their mind is racing and they're
thinking about what he's about to do
then quote both is a character there the
fact that he don't think I told him is
the fact is you don't think that you put
fear in players is just asinine to me
there it's just the makeup of this
divine he puts fear into itself as a
faculty and also the guards just like on
stair bucks yeah I think it's the
totality of this deal and I don't think
it's just one I think it's just I've
been dealing with Buckner all day now I
got to deal with D for
you know so it's just I think it's just
a it's the totality of the b-line that
just makes us so special in a hard thing
to deal with do you guys have a name for
yourself no people's asses that we're
not thinking of and we don't let it come
you gonna let it come do I have a name
can I give you one I'm look the first
couple I heard was pretty bad so I hope
you can come windy this is my forte I
know this is our first conversation
you're in my wheelhouse here now there's
you know obviously Gold Rush has been
something out there how about this gold
crush you're the gold crush your
thoughts Dee Ford gold Christ you have
to explain though you have to explain
like why gold crush well I mean is the
gold rush of San Francisco the famed
gold rush of San Francisco you're the
gold crush of San Francisco meaning we
crush crush your opponents across
quarterbacks hey look that's the best
we've gotten so far I'd say that
clubhouse leader I'm looking for lookout
rate the word we in a group chat right
now I was great to work because I've
been I've been trying to get Matt Ryan
to change his nickname from Maddie eyes
to the natural for years d know but so
the natural does not is what you're
saying and I try to get I try to get my
home's to go with the Pat role but he
didn't like that one either oh my gosh
Steve Ford here on the right choice Joe
I do what what now you're looking I'm
sure across the NFL landscape right now
what do you think about Derrick Henry
and what he's been bringing from his
side of the football
I mean what do you mad think at this
point I don't think I'm
single dominants like this running back
in the post see I don't have to be
careful when I say that produces a lot
of historical running back who made them
marching postseason but this is very
impressive to watch and I think
especially at this time you have you see
a lot of guys making business decisions
time the tackling you know that's hard
to face that's hard to face that's a big
guy he can I played against him in
college so I know I know
I played against him once when I was in
KC mm-hmm stuff got tough gotta tackle
man and good luck to the opponents man
we just really got a such a big boy
pants on there's not a secret what
they're doing they're gonna give him the
rock even lay players happen so more
power to him has anybody caused you to
ever make a business decision Dean at
Auburn Kansas City San Francisco anybody
not even cam and practice back in the
day the national championship cam not
even ham not even I can not even that
was a stressful thing watch so what was
that like actually walk me through that
Heisman cam you know what's crazy is
camera like when I say this he first got
here we were training and cam really
struggled with one team the first guy
talked all know everybody I just
remember guys looking around like it's
our quarterback no big guy way to think
about cam he never liked being defeated
by anything and I was close to the
roommate a total Freeman
he was always telling me they can would
get up in the morning and was just run
and was just as Ryan I think that was
the first sign of greatness from camp
when I saw him struggled that we all
struggle with when teams cam didn't like
the fact that you struggle
he hated that and so he made sure that
he defeated those workouts just like
anything else and it's this little
saying that we have going on when I
first got there same friend it's how you
do anything is how you do everything and
it's just that was my first whiff of
cans of greatness just something is
Lewis 110 he did not like and he he
crushed every workout from that point on
which was it's crazy because he's a bit
quarterback he's a big guy and that was
the special thing watch my camera listen
to gospel music every morning he was
very grounded
he had a foundation I knew he was going
to be special he inspired me inspired me
to the fullest he pushed he pushed me
and workouts I don't think he even
realized how much he because I never
said anything I just saw and every and
every day that I saw him I wanted to
match him he didn't even know that he
didn't know that at all but I just said
yeah I want I'm gonna be great like that
too I was a sophomore at the time kind
of figuring myself out and it was Kim it
was the Kami Nick show and so every day
I would watch him I'm like I'm gonna be
that he would come back each year once
he got to the league he would come back
talk to us and every year he put some in
me you know I don't think he realized
that his day because you don't really
want to get a chance to speak a lot but
he put a lot of inspiration in me and
you know that was a special thing to
watch she changed my game I know my
complete know what that Dee Ford here on
the Richardson show and then obviously
everything's clearly worked out for you
last one for you if you're fortunate to
get to the bowl and you see Kansas City
there what's that going to mean for you
a whole lot I got so much love for so
many people over there and and you know
what it's like playing your brother you
know it's different is this gonna be
different I think anybody who would say
otherwise is lying to you it's going to
be there
it's gonna be fine
and I would love to see that I would
love to see that and I'm gonna talk I'm
going to talk talk talk the whole game I
don't talk a lot I'm going to talk
anyone at anyone in particular who
Kelsey so it's gonna be so fun I don't
know as I'm gonna shoot my side at
everybody it's gonna it's gonna be it's
going to be a very fun experience we're
all competitors at heart man we used to
go at it it's gonna go back to those
long days and training camp when we used
to go at it we were embarrassed each
other I had to cover kills 101 the in
training camp so imagine that one on one
route so and he had to block me one on
one passwords too so I gave we give back
it's gonna be just like old times so you
know we're gonna be competing I love the
team that I'm with right now we have a
great thing going right now and you know
it's gonna be it's gonna be special I
can't be more blessed to be in this
position right now right well best of
luck against the Packers for you to
maybe get that opportunity against
Kansas City this has been a blast
really appreciate it hopefully we get to
chat some more I love the honor I
appreciate you right back at your D and
go run tell that to everybody the gold
cross go across where the gold rush you
look at bow so you look at Buckner and
say we're the members of the gold crush
okay am I allowed to tell you to get
cricket to do you know what here's the
thing is I have thick skin okay I can
take I'm trying to get my family to get
some thick skin now not a lot of people
have I'm a glass-half-full guy
you we're gonna make t-shirts off of
this and people will be calling you the
gold crush
there will be no crickets it's the
opposite yes
is why your retirement I love right back
at your d4 let's chat again sir you got
it you guys
that's d4 and everybody for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app